all right everybody this is it
finally awesome comics episode 1 we're
gonna be talking about Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice okay so I want to
explain what awesome comics is really
quick this is your one-stop shop for
everything comic book entertainment so
we're gonna be talking about the books
but we're also going to be talking about
movies TV shows anything else that comes
out as comic book related we're going to
be able to cover that on the show
so we're gonna go into Batman V Superman
in a second but first one introduce our
guest today might as well go with the
the guy to my left over here you know
them as the stalls our critic that guy
with the glasses the bum Chester a bum
I thought character that's just my side
right
this is mr. Doug Walker how's it going
doc very good and it's versus don't say
B it's versus one more syllable you know
it's a court case basically okay so
going over to his left you have miss
Heather ruse how's it going hey good
how's it going you you excited for talk
about Bambi Superman I am yeah I have
some opinions I do isn't it great I got
it at a advance screening on Wednesday
okay how perfect and Wednesday stops
Livingston I did I hate you now or do I
she saw it earlier and then later I
could put this off maybe the back go
into my right this is Miss Iona Wade hi
may recognize Ana from our c2e2 coverage
and everybody at this table actually and
of course my pal to the right of ion mr.
Brian Porter so that's an interesting
shirt you got there Porter yeah DC you
know I wanted to make statement well
we're gonna get to the statements in a
moment here okay so what we're going to
be doing here is talking about band V
Superman we're gonna go into no spoilers
first just overall impressions and
everything and I will give you a warning
before we go into spoilers in case you
haven't seen the movie yet and then
we're going to get dig deep into the
movie that we just saw so okay so BBS
the the best little review quote that
I've seen so far is this let me read it
to you mm BBS a ponderous smothering /
pixelated zeppelin crash
movie scored by a choir that sounds like
it's being drowned in lava best one are
I saw that too our line I thought that
was perfect yes so I'm with
representation what do you guys think
overall no spoilers also what Jana
justice - Donna yawning - that was all
good idea what he saw for it since
you're like let me hear what do you
think of BBS it was awful it was awful
it was a really bad movie this is a
really restate montañas it was
completely unrelated um I didn't like it
really at all there's only a couple of
things that I thought were okay or
worked not necessarily good or shining
things in the movie who's just like that
doesn't suck I think you Harsha review I
I'm not saying that you guys I would
necessarily see it again but I'm I don't
think I will but I liked it I would see
it I would see it again to like kind of
understand why it's getting such a bad
rap I also wasn't expecting much from it
when I went to see it because I saw that
it was getting such bad I think anybody
was just putting that out there
the expectations bar was that low people
over 13 were not looking forward to it
after the review of this right oh it was
not as bad as it's getting though I
don't think it was I tend to agree I
think that it's not good movie I don't
think it's good but I went in after
seeing the reviews right really lowering
the bar I didn't like Man of Steel I
think that's like made two good scenes
in Mansfield I liked and the rest is a
bore to me so I was lowering the bar I
said okay just give me something
entertaining I saw Jesse Eisenberg I'm
like just be so awkward and weird that I
can laugh at at least you know just give
me something kind of fun and for me a
good even though it makes no sense to me
like none of it makes any sense a good
half of the movie I found legitimately
entertaining like actually like this is
kind of cool action I like batfleck that
I thought he was a a lot fun and the way
it look I like Wonder Woman I you know
and I like some of the questions they
were asking if I were more interesting
to Man of Steel so for good half of it I
found myself kind of getting sucked in
and even when they're redoing like the
parents origin in the opening I'm like
oh we're doing this again come on
some of those shots with the pearls and
some of the points of view and stuff I'm
like this is new and I like this do you
love when little Bruce is ascending what
do you guess it is
so all the bats come and they're just
replaying Batman Begins all the best fly
around he starts flying up ago huh and
then he says and that's where the dream
ends I'm like thank Jesus
no I'm care with you a good half of it I
really like and though I don't know if I
see the whole thing again I wouldn't
mind seeing it like maybe I'm DVD and
sort of skipping around something like
this here's the problem I have with like
the good part though is they were all we
knew what was coming every time a
trailer gave away everything I think we
got into that in the spoiler talk
Heather I want to get your overall
opinion no spoilers yeah I mean I agree
with what you guys have said about how
it was like 50% good and if anything
that's what made it frustrating because
you saw that it had potential to go
somewhere and be good and it just fell
short like I walked out of the theater
and said it should have been called
called dawn of disappointment well cuz
you had those moments where you saw what
it could have been and I wanted it to be
that the whole time but those moments
that were bad were really bad but it
wasn't Man of Steel bad we're gonna go
into spoilers now so if you've been
watching up until now you haven't seen
it yet if you don't want any we know you
all saw it just in case
what do you guys think of Batman what do
you think yeah it was alright
that seems better than I expected
universally the most positive thing
about the movies banner Ben Affleck's
performance as Batman I you know and
that is the one it's the first time ever
I think so you know Keaton did his own
Batman I think it really worked Kevin
Conroy I thought was very much the comic
Batman but sort of a cartoon Bruce Wayne
which I thought was fine this felt like
a comic Batman and a comic Bruce Wayne
and to me it's like after keen after
Conroy it it's a flick now yeah he just
most people down
he shoots people in the back right yeah
he straight-up stabbed
yeah what are you guys think of Batman
totally crossing the line obliterating
the law you know when she's napping and
killing people even when he does it like
stab or shoot with a gun people he brand
them so that they can't die not to
preview someone else can stab but but
it's okay he didn't bring it likes
Luthor hello what the Darwin had pretty
much killed Superman why does again no
spoilers we're in the eye
Zack Snyder did an interview and he said
that he there was a supercut on YouTube
about how many kills Batman did in the
Nolan's and then even further back in
like the Keaton era and all that stuff
and so he says you know they did it kind
of like not 100% killing him and so he
kind of did it like that by proxy he
said he says it wasn't really murder he
thought of it more as manslaughter I
don't like bad it was not my favorite
thing that he was so edgy and darker
like just mowing people down and I
understand they're going for like the
Frank Miller more edgy like dark Batman
but they didn't have that same kind of
element that element of like seeing him
snap basically like they made allusion
to the fact that he's been doing this
for a while but I wanted a little bit
more build-up before like oh hey he's
branding people now yeah
just so you know I'll bring him I think
everything or the most interesting parts
of this Batman have already happened so
like I want to see some kind of prequel
movie or something I hate prequels by
the way but for this because it's so
freakin thin I want to see how you know
Jason Todd or whoever Robin that was
like how he got killed by the Joker or
whatever is going on with that I want to
see how bad became this heart because I
think that's kind of what what the
catalyst is for him going crazy like he
is in this movie you know I'll I'll
strongly disagree on all that honestly
because with Batman killing a we have
seen it before I'll stop my brother
about this and we both agreed that this
Batman and the people he kills is just a
little harsher than the Keaton Batman
because you know he's he's setting
people on fire and throwing him off
cliffs and stuff like that and hearsay
that you know he's he's doing all this
stuff but with this one I felt I like
that they don't go into too much detail
because there's a scene where you look
at this
at suit they surprisingly kept of the
Joker spray-painting haha I got the last
lap and even if you don't know what that
is you see them look at it's like you
can guess something really bad happy if
you know the comics you can do a little
bit more and to me like I like that you
kind of just fill in the blanks and you
fill in the gaps and I think it's kind
of better leaving that kind of ambiguous
oh you don't know what happened and just
the worst-case scenario is what you put
in there and by the end I think they're
indicating he does change I mean I think
that's why he punches the wall instead
of you know Luther laughs I want to talk
about Wonder Woman but Wonder Woman is
kind of the wild card in this the BBS
thing dog what do you think wonderful
really the best partnership in this
movie is not Batman and Superman it is
Batman Wonder Woman anytime they were
together
and they're just are sitting there with
their arms full just yeah and then
they're just are saying stuff
well not look at each other and stuff I
love those cliches I thought was really
badass
and when she shows up finally at the end
you know doing the fight and stuff they
bring out the lasso and the lasso works
it actually looks legitimately cool and
anytime that music came out the only
time I got like excited in this movie
was whenever that Wonder Woman theme
played it like you're go go go and I'm
like I really wants the owner woman
moving oh yeah I am so excited for one
of everything they set up Wonder Woman
is I'm I'm always oh yes I could have
done more Wonder Woman personally but I
guess leave the onliest Lenny more yeah
we probably got having Superman industry
she was definitely my favorite part of
the movie I mean every scene she stole
or like you were saying the chemistry
with her and Batman was awesome so every
scene
she stole I thought she was my favorite
part of the movie um they set it up
really well she was by far the most
competent of them as well like I know
that sounds terrible but Batman and
Superman kind of seemed incompetent and
then one woman shows up she's like I got
this she didn't detract from a movie at
all she wasn't a detriment to the movie
she was fine um she did okay is Wonder
Woman I mean I personally I didn't like
her a cast as Wonder Woman I think there
was plenty of other better choices out
there just for the physicality and
whatnot but her performance as Wonder
Woman has Diana
Diana and one woman separate were both
okay they were fine but I don't think
she had a point in the movie like she
they could have taken out Wonder Woman
entirely and you would have lost nothing
I think the the picture that we saw the
world war one picture with Steve Trevor
being played by Chris Pine now that got
me probably most excited out of the
whole movie yeah it's still weird to
have it in World War one but you know
again it's like I just seeing everything
that they've done and show and I'm like
I'm open to it
Zoomer goes Lex Luthor hahahahahaha
chucker Berg arsy someone someone else
take this I can't even get unpopular
opinion I actually kind of thought it
was fun okay I enjoyed it like he was
just batshit crazy it was like he was
absolutely insane right I'm crazy I
thought it was fun it wasn't like any
deep character choice yeah you know lady
laughs I enjoyed it it was fun he made
it hit make it jointly could I committed
to something wait someone should have
been like oh you guys this isn't really
fitting with the rest it didn't have the
like fun crazy enough to like be that
little bit of like oh cool we get like a
little like comedic relief it wasn't
enough comedic relief but also didn't
have like the depth to be like Oh like
cool Luther he's like crazy person it
was also Joker ask about like yeah
nothing you did not not yes they needed
to go in one direction or the other and
I don't I don't bling Jesse Eisenberg
for that I don't think that was I think
he went a hundred percent yeah he went
for it and he chose to do something good
for you didn't work even though I agree
he committed to it and I'm sure you
tried as hard as I never felt that this
is a clear character here I felt this
was a performance trying to find an
identity I thought even it's like ruin
scenes personally write about the wrong
many just have gotten so big with some
people who don't think something smarter
get in your space can we talk about the
the flash and all the talk about the
tie-ins yeah the time like okay we see
in the surveillance footage we see
Aquaman we see flash BC cyborg okay
no TYIN what so first of the scenes in
this though they like throwing some
flash for Scotchgard all this stuff it
felt like okay and now to interrupt your
regular program it seems like an
afterthought yeah like an afterthought
that was just pieced in I mean it was an
interesting way to do it Heather final
thoughts I mean it was not great it was
not awful it was frustrating as I said
earlier it was just a frustrating
experience especially as a DC fan I
wanted to see so much more they tried to
put so much in it that everything just
got lost muddled and watered down so I
would still recommend people to see it
like I want people to support TC because
I love DC but it was not the greatest
product they could have put forth
especially with the elements that they
had of what it could have been okay Ryan
ah Zack Snyder is the Joel Schumacher of
this decade and he should be he should
be fired and never allowed near a camera
or a comic book ever again okay yeah
follow that no I I think it's I think
it's harshly judged I think visually
it's a really really entertaining movie
you get some cool costumes in it the
Superman suit the cool Kryptonian text
that's embedded in there awesome there's
some cool like painting through it you
get the visual even in the background of
like man for Scott or or like power play
and stuff
I love visually the whole movie it's a
really cool looking the nightmare Batman
or whatever we're calling it with the
flash-forward the para Dean's there's
some cool visually things okay yeah go
see it um I think any die-hard DC fan
that grew up with these stories really
holds these stories close and loves
Batman Superman is probably not going to
like this or at least at the very least
be very frustrated at the choices made
um I think I don't think that's who it's
made for even though it should be it's
know it's made for I think it's made for
kind of a transformer audience people
that want to see something loud and
violent and cool and fights and I think
that's kind of attitude I want in going
you know gonna watch it after mana steel
I think you're going with that attitude
you at least like half of it if you
didn't check out our c2e2 coverage there
are several videos up there so go check
that out we covered the Chicago comic
and Entertainment Expo last week and
we're going to give you a little preview
of all that right now so take it away we
are here at c2e2 yeah that's right the
Chicago comic and entertainment expo you
excited I'm excited yes yes yes yes yes
yeah so let's go on into the con and get
to it
all right here with Austin st. John the
original read file Ranger for money more
power rangers Scott Snyder and Greg
Capullo artist and writer of Batman here
with Karen Ashley the second Yellow
Ranger for money more from Power Rangers
hey it's Channel awesome if I didn't
know you guys are gonna be here weird
right
hey pal what's your name Brian Porter hi
I'm Ayanna Heather Heather are you
interested in co-hosting a comic book
talk show with me and my friend Porter
here sure why not
sure sure
we are Groot that's awesome
comments
I'm here with Batman today so Batman how
old are you seven my two new best
friends this is Ellie and this is Nia
who is your favorite superhero
Wonder Woman I'm here with my friend Joe
and he's dressed as cubone hey aren't
you Jim Jane you're us Jim J Ross Jim J
Roz no Jam would you like me to cut you
in half
no sir last time I saw you you were a
little less clothing more menacing you
really need to take care of this you
need to get a better brush or something
that's going to do it for c2e2 2016
until next time let's flip house a lot
of fun I hope we go to a couple more con
soon because that was a lot of fun okay
so this is gonna be Porter's pick of the
week this week go ahead and take it away
mr. pow right we've got Batman versus
Superman the greatest battles now if you
want to see something that actually
doesn't let you down is a really amazing
you picked this this pick this book up
it's got I think seven stories in it
three of them are iconic Batman vs
Superman stories you've got Batman hush
you've got the Dark Knight Returns which
is amazing and you've got the new one by
Scott Snyder and Greg Capullo which I
just interviewed if you haven't seen
that yet go watch the interview
I called endgame which is an amazing
story with a Superman fighting Batman
all joker fight it's pretty crazy so
pick it up it's amazing this won't let
you down unlike everything else with
that title all right so you in the
animated movie well just just the movie
just this movie just this movie in case
you guys didn't see these are Batman
Superman you're real I mean just this
one's actually pretty good I don't know
why I got that if you are ball insane
this is all awful oh no this is good
this is good I like to find out how
Chocula Franken berry blueberry and I
done that this is my tea and its
redshift an abomination it's your duty
I beat you to it I mean into it okay Wow
I've got an incredible endorsement so
yeah they're terrible don't you um so
until next time next week we're going to
be reviewing daredevil season 2 the
Netflix series so make sure you come
back for that that's something that we
all agree is pretty good oh yeah
absolutely next time absolutely okay so
for all you guys mr. Brian Porter Iona
Wade
Heather Roose Doug Walker I'm Walter
Bernays yack
until next time we'll see you on the
next page
you